let's get the latest uh analysis of the
situation on the ground in ukraine now
joining me is the defense and security
analyst professor michael clark michael
great to see you zoice thanks so much
for joining me so let's talk about uh
the east first of all mario paul now in
russian hands how has that changed the
battle for the east and i guess freed up
some russian forces yes i mean it freed
those forces up a couple of weeks ago
and what's happened is those forces have
gone north to veliko novosuka which is
not an important place in geographical
terms but it's important for this
offensive because russian troops have
been dug in around there south of that
area for a while now they've got out of
the defenses and they're beginning to
move they hope towards don yet so you
can see this east-west movement between
valencia novosilka and don yes they're
trying to consolidate that bit of the of
the front
the real battle is still going on at
svero donetsk further north that is
surrounded on three sides the russians
have got to take that
and the essence of the donbass is still
slaviansk and kramatos which are north
and south i mean in the middle of that
of that area until they've taken those
two cities they don't control the
donbass and they're still fairly long
way away from that because what they're
doing is they're offensive they're
getting smaller and smaller they're
still bringing troops in they're still
pushing they're still gaining but
they're not gaining any sort of outright
victories they're pushing in small units
they're taking bite-sized small chunks
out of the front as they go does freeing
up the mariopol troops change the debate
there or not really well it gives them
more options around don yes that's the
point and that's been going on for a
week or so it's basically got them out
of defense into advancement but they're
advancing in company size which is 120
130 men not a
a battalion tactical group of 700 men
small small steps uh let's uh focus now
a bit on the on the south west of the
country and and is there as much focus
for the russians on this region or or
more up in the east it's much more in
the east but they are doing something
around kershaw they're pushing back
against um uh ukrainian gains i mean
ukrainians were quite close to cursing a
little while ago they look as if they're
having another go at mikalaya which they
couldn't get past uh a month or more ago
but what they're doing is they're going
down to the coast instead of attacking
mikolav across the the land to the north
of the river it looks as if they're
going to the coast and they're trying to
dislodge those ukrainian forces along
the the uh the delta of the river in
effect so it looks as if they're going
to try to get to mikolai from the south
but i have to say they've still got a
long way to go and and they are they've
got a lot to worry about the russians in
that area because kershaw itself is not
particularly safe for them
and then we've had some discussion
points some news come out but russia's
got suddenly superior weaponry and and
what do you make of that already
laughing oh yeah what are we looking at
here well this is the terminator 2
which is an armored actually called the
terminator 2. it's called terminator 2.
and the russians love it they talk about
it all the time now there's a terminator
3 on the way but we haven't really seen
it yet
you know they say that one of the few
sets of films where the sequels were
getting better though
in this case maybe not maybe not um
you know a camel is is is called a horse
designed by committee
well this is a tank designed by a
committee it's a t-72 hull which is a
solid old-fashioned hull and they've
piled onto it all the weapons that
soldiers would like to have in an urban
area not for a big tank battle but
inside a city where they're fighting so
it's got two 30 millimeter cannons on it
it's got four rocket launchers it's got
um
two big grenade launchers on the back
it's got smoke grenade launchers a heavy
machine gun it's full of weapons
and it's not clear how many they've got
and it's not clear if it's any use to
them in the battle that they're fighting
at the moment if they end up fighting
inside the cities
these could be formidable but the
russians love them i think they've
talked about them much more for the
benefit of public opinion to be honest
rather than the the troops who are doing
the fighting at the moment in the
donbass well as always uh michael i'm
glad we've got you because what you just
described and what we're looking at
otherwise looks quite impressive it's a
camel it's a camel uh professor michael
clark as ever thanks so much